[موسيقى]
من هذا الماضي المجيد ورثه المدينه كنزا
استثنائيا وهو مسجد جمعه الذي يعود تاريخه
الى القرن العاشر الميلادي اقدم جامع ليس
في هرر فقط بل في عموم شرق افريقيا حافظ
الهرريون على تقاليد المسجد المتوارثه فلم
يتغير شكله المعماري الاساسي رغم الترميم
والتحديث
خلف مسجد جمعه فصل لقصه هذه المدينه من
مجد وتاريخ عريق حضاره تحدت الزمن واسهمت
في انتشار الاسلام على يد امرائها ليس في
اثيوبيا فحسب بل في شرق افريقيا وكانت مقر
حكم وسياده روى لنا تفاصيلها احد احفاد
الامير نور مجاهد
جهود اجدادنا كانت احد اهم عوامل الانتشار
الدين الاسلامي ليس في منطقه هرر واثيوبيا
فحسب بل في جل مناطق الشرقي القاره
الافريقيه
وما سهل عليهم ذلك انهم كانوا يناصرون
اصحاب الحق ايا كان دينه وعرقه
وكانوا يؤمنون بالمساواه واعاده الحقوق
الى اصحابها والتاريخ يشهد على وقوف
الهرريين مع الصومال في القرن الماضي
فالهرريون لا يعملون لدنياهم وينسون
اخرتهم هذا ما ورثناه من اجدادنا ونورثه
نحن للاجيال القادمه وما نزرعه في ابنائنا
واحفادنا حتى تصبح نصره المظلوم عاده لدى
اجيال هرر القادمه